THE WHITE HOUSE RIGHT NOW THE
NEED FOR LEADERSHIP CRITICAL
AND WE’RE GOING TO BRING IN MARC
SHORT, CHIEF OF STAFF TO VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE WHO JOINS
US THIS MORNING, MARK THANKS SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
FIRST OF ALL JUST TOP LINE.
YOU’RE THERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
YOU’RE AROUND THE VICE PRESIDENT
, THE PRESIDENT AS
THESE CRITICAL DECISIONS ARE
BEING MADE RIGHT BEFORE PRESS
CONFERENCES EVERYONE IS WATCHING
TAKE US BEHIND THE SCENES OF
THIS PROCESS RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL GOOD MORNING, PETE
THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
PETE: GOOD MORNING.
>> THE TASK FORCE THAT MEETS
DAILY THE VICE PRESIDENT WILL BE
MEETING AGAIN THIS MORNING AT
10:00.
TYPICALLY WE BRING ALL SECTORS
OF THE GOVERNMENT TOGETHER TO
BRING TO THE FLOOR THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES AND THEN THE
VICE PRESIDENT TYPICALLY
RAISES DECISIONS THAT NEED TO BE
MADE TO THE PRESIDENT BUT I
CAN’T TELL YOU TO YOUR LAST
SEGMENT, PETE HOW ENCOURAGED WE
ARE TO SEE ALL OF AMERICA COMING
TOGETHER AND THE SPIRIT OF
AMERICA IS INSPIRING TO ALL OF
US AND YOU’VE SEEN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR PARTNER AND REACH OUT TO
US AND SAY WE WANT TO RETROFIT
OUR MANUFACTURING FACILITIES, TO
PROVIDE MORE MEDICAL SUPPLIES IF
NEEDED.
WE WANT TO BE THERE TO HELP AND
PROVIDE SUPPLIES TO THOSE MOST
IN NEED, AND WE SEE THAT FROM
PASTORS AS WELL AND IT’S I THINK
WE’RE VERY ENCOURAGED THAT WE’RE
GOING TO GET OVER THIS HUMP IN
THE SPAN TYPICALLY BEEN SIX TO
EIGHT WEEKS WHERE WE SEEN THE
OUTBREAKS IN ASIA, AND WHERE
WE SEEN THEM ELSEWHERE, AND SO
WE’RE ENCOURAGED WITH THE WAY
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
COOPERATING WITH THE 15-DAY
GUIDANCE THE PRESIDENT PROVIDED
TO ALL AMERICANS.
JEDEDIAH: MARK THERE’S BEEN A
RUMOR ABOUT A NATIONWIDE
QUARANTINE.
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT?
>> SURE, THAT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT’S BEEN DISCUSSED INSIDE OUR
TASK FORCE MEETINGS, IT’S NOT ON
THE AGENDA TODAY.
THERE ARE NO PLANS FOR A
NATIONWIDE QUARANTINE.
PETE: SO WHEN FOLKS SEE THE
MILITARY MOBILIZED,
THERE’S RUMORS OF THE NATIONAL
GUARD, I’M IN THE NATIONAL GUARD
, THERE’S NO TALK OF THIS ,
THERE’S BEEN NO DIRECTIVE OF
THIS.
>> YOU WILL SEE IT USED IN
CERTAIN PLACES AND STATES TO
SUPPLEMENT WHAT’S HAPPENING IN
HEALTHCARE PLACES BUT SPEAK TO
THAT IF YOU WOULD.
>> LET’S BREAK THAT DOWN FOR A
SECOND, PETE BECAUSE YOU’RE
RIGHT.
TYPICALLY NATIONAL GUARD IS
MOBILIZED AT THE GOVERNOR’S
DIRECTION AND WHAT WE’RE SEEING
IS THAT THREE STATES HAVE MORE
THAN 50% OF THE CASES, AND IN
FACT MORE THAN 50% OF NEW CASES
UNFORTUNATELY FOR YOU ALL ARE IN
NEW YORK CITY.
BUT WHAT WE’RE SEEING IS THAT
THE CONTAGION IS WASHINGTON,
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK STATE, AND
THE FATALITIES THAT WE WERE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT OBVIOUSLY
CALIFORNIA AND WASHINGTON AND
NEW YORK WERE NOW BASICALLY AT
250-PLUS.
WHAT WE HAD SAID THE PRESIDENT
YOU HEARD SAID WHEN THE INITIAL
NUMBERS CAME OUT FROM THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION THAT THE
FATALITY RATE WAS ABOUT 3.5%
, AMONG THOSE HERE IN
AMERICA, WE’RE NOW DOWN UNDER
1.5% AND I KNOW THAT DOESN’T
GIVE COMFORT TO THE FAMILIES
THAT HAVE LOST LOVED ONES BUT
THE REALITY IS THAT WILL WE
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION, NO
MORE PEOPLE PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING, YOU’RE CONTINUING TO
SEE THOSE NUMBERS COME DOWN AND
AS WE GET MORE TESTS OUT IN THE
MARKET NATURALLY YOU’LL SEE
THE MEDIA EXPOSED SO THERE’S
MORE CASES THAT TEST POSITIVE,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, YOU’RE SEE
SEEING FATALITY RATE
CONTINUES TO COME DOWN, AND I
THINK AS WE GET MORE INFORMATION
, WE PROVIDE MORE
THERAPEUTICS THAT COME ON THE
MARKET IN THE COMING WEEKS
WE’RE ENCOURAGED THAT TREND WILL
CONTINUE.
PETE: ABSOLUTELY.
MARK, AND IN YOUR OFFICE, IT
HASN’T GONE WITHOUT TOUCHING THE
VICE PRESIDENT’ OFFICE WE
HEARD REPORTS THAT A STAFFER IN
THE VICE PRESIDENT’S OFFICE HAS
TESTED POSITIVE FOR CORONAVIRUS.
TALK TO US ABOUT THAT.
DID THE VICE PRESIDENT,
PRESIDENT HAVE ANY INTERACTION
WITH THAT INDIVIDUAL?
>> I’M PLEASED TO REPORT THAT
THAT INDIVIDUAL IS DOING WELL.
I’VE TALKED TO HIM LAST NIGHT,
SEVERAL TIMES.
HE BASICALLY HAD A COUPLE DAYS
OF COLD-LIKE SYMPTOMS.
HE TESTED POSITIVE THURSDAY
NIGHT, HE WAS NOT IN THE OFFICE
TUESDAY, WEDNESDAY, THURSDAY,
FRIDAY.
HE HAS HAD NO DIRECT CONTACT
WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT OR  THE
PRESIDENT.
WE’VE HAD THE NORMAL CONTACT
TRACING, LED BY THE WHITE HOUSE
PHYSICIAN’S OFFICE TO GO THROUGH
WHO HE MAY HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT
WITH PREVIOUSLY AND SOME STAFF
WILL TAKE NECESSARY PRECAUTIONS
BUT I’M PLEASED TO REPORT THAT
HE HAD VERY MILD SYMPTOMS AND IS
DOING REALLY WELL.
TODD: MARK THIS HAS NOT BEEN AN
EASY WEEK BUT ANY STRETCH OF
THE IMAGINATION AND NEXT WEEK
YOU HEAR TALK AMONGST YOUR
FRIENDS AND FAMILY WE DON’T KNOW
WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN AND
THERE’S CONCERN TESTING IS RAMP
ED UP,NIH WARNING THERE
COULD BE 70,000 CASES IN THE
U.S. BY NEXT WEEK, DR.  FAUC
I SAYING IT’S UNCLEAR
WHEN COVID-19 IS GOING TO REACH
ITS PEAK.
BASED UPON THE DISCUSSIONS THAT
YOU HAVE HAD, WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT, AND THE MEETINGS THAT
HE HAS HAD, AND BASED UPON THE
INFORMATION YOU’RE ALLOWED
TO TELL US, WHAT DO YOU
ANTICIPATE FOR THE NEXT SEVEN
DAYS?
>> WELL, TODD, I’M PLEASED TO
TELL YOU WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT
AND THE PRESIDENT’S LEADERSHIP
WE PULLED TOGETHER A LARGE
NUMBER OF PRIVATE SECTOR LAB
COMPANIES WHO HAVE PROVIDED MANY
MORE TESTS ON THE MARKET.
THE NUMBER OF TESTS AVAILABLE
HAS GROWN 10-FOLD THIS WEEK
ALONE AND WE’LL PROBABLY SEE
THAT AGAIN NEXT WEEK SO BY
DEDUCTION AS MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE ARE TESTED YOU’RE GOING
TO SEE THOSE NUMBERS GO UP BUT
ENCOURAGING I THINK FOR YOUR
AUDIENCE IS THAT WE’VE ONLY BEEN
ASKING PEOPLE WHO HAVE SYMPTOMS,
FEVER, RESPIRATORY PROBLEMS,
OTHERS TO GET TESTED SO ONLY
THOSE WITH SYMPTOMS ARE GETTING
TESTED, AND WHAT WE’RE SEEING IS
LESS THAN 10% ARE ACTUALLY
INFECTED.
LET’S KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS ALSO
FLU SEASON, IT’S ALLERGY SEASON,
AND SO THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE GETTING TESTED ARE
TESTING NEGATIVE, AND EVEN THOSE
WHO TEST POSITIVE AS WE’VE
SAID FROM THE VERY BEGINNING,
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE
PEOPLE DO NOT FACE A RISK
OF SEVERE ILLNESS.
THE PRECAUTIONS THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT IN
PLACE IS OUT OF ABUNDANCE OF
PRECAUTION TO PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE, THE SENIORS WITH
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS AND
THAT’S THE BACKBONE OF A POLICY
RECOMMENDATION TO BE EXTRA
CAUTIOUS BUT WHAT WE’RE SEEING
AND YOU WILL SEE MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE TEST POSITIVE NEXT WEEK,
AS MORE TESTS ARE AVAILABLE BUT
A LOT OF PEOPLE FOR INSTANCE
LIKE THE MEMBER ON OUR STAFF
WILL HAVE VERY MILD SYMPTOMS OR
ACTUALLY BE ASYMPTOMATIC
ALTOGETHER.
PETE: MARK WE ONLY HAVE A MOMENT
AND WE’RE FOCUSED ON HOW WE’RE
REACTING AS A COUNTRY BUT THERE
HAVE BEEN REPORTS RECENTLY THAT
IF CHINA HAD ACTED SOONER IF
THEY HAD BEEN HONEST AND HAD
TRANSPARENCY FROM THE BEGINNING
A LOT OF THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED, PRESIDENT CALLING IT
THE CHINESE VIRUS.
WHAT IS THE WHITE HOUSE DOING TO
SORT OF HOLD CHINA RESPONSIBLE
FOR  UNLEASHING A LOT OF THIS?
>> WELL, PETE I THINK THERE’S
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
I DO THINK IT’S TRUE IF THEY HAD
BEEN MORE FORTHCOMING FROM THE
BEGINNING IT WOULD HAVE HELP
ED OTHER NATIONS TO BELTER
PREPARE FOR THIS OUTBREAK.
HAVING SAID THAT I THINK THERE
WILL BE FUTURE ACTIONS DOWN THE
ROAD.
RIGHT NOW, CHINA HAS BEEN TRYING
TO PROVIDE EQUIPMENT WHERE
THERE’S DEFICITS TO OTHER PEOPLE
AND SO I THINK THERE WILL BE
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
RESPONSIBILITY THEY SHOULD HAVE
AND SHOULD TAKE IN WAYS THAT
THEY WERE TRYING TO HIDE
INFORMATION.
WE ALSO OBVIOUSLY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS, AND ALLEGING IT CAME
FROM OTHER PLACES, BUT I THINK
THERE’S PROBABLY A DAY AND A
TIME FOR MORE APPROPRIATE
ACTIONS WITH CHINA.
PETE: YOU GOT IT.
MARC SHORT, THANK YOU, YOU’RE A
BUSY MAN THESE DAYS WE